[Musique]
évidemment c'est un truc de fou c'est lg
qui montre au stade quoi j'avoue ce fou
en tant qu'une prise il paye mon gars à
west et chardy c'est très très cher
ouais enfin justement tu te rappelles
quand on était à dubaï ouais c'était
nouveau resté là c'était bien moi je
t'avais avorter les billets
attendaient acquis mais moi je t'invite
chez moi là pour regarder le match
tranquille entre potes là et toi tu me
parles d'oseille très haut c'était play
mélangez pas tout je sais papa d'oseille
juste en train de dire que ça fait six
mois qu'on est revenu dubaï 6 mois
frères six mois le pays ils ont fini de
construire ça il ya plus rien à faire et
j'ai toujours pas vu l'argent mais c'est
pas bien quand notre ami tiens tiens ça
s'emballe quand ton argent tu toi c'est
ton argent frais arrête de me parler
jaoui et surtout arrête de me parler
d'amitié pourquoi j'ai des lic j'ai
besoin d'argent c'était mon pas tu
meures montage en fait moi je ne vais
pas m'arrêter de vivre parce que tu as
besoin de l'argent que j'étais en compte
les frais non je n'ai pas dit ça arrête
de devenir fou avant de construire une
fan zone dans ton salon rend bousseton
poteau attend frère est fière de moi je
prends pas si bien dire thema la bête
personnes là sur la très très cher ce
matin ça tue pas
je vous en prie pour acheter une télé un
rétroprojecteur et tu t'es pas dit je
rembourse mon pote d'abord fait ma mère
que ça ça nous appartient tous les deux
par capcom en bourse était un pouce
droit tu viens chez moi qui aura 14
arrête avec tes mots de fou la raquette
je te raconte pas prêt ce taux de primes
au large en otage et frère la vie de
merde qu'il va rembourser s'alimente
garde partagée une semaine sur deux il
garde partagée de quoi fils d'aaron
teulade à rome mais t'as fait quoi pour
toi c'est toi qui a sorti du carton à
sans les abîmer nato douce - c'est toi
qui les a pris chez toi alors que
personne ne voulait le prendre ce qui
est un prix indécent qu'il faut il est
tombé france contre le vhc trop chers
les prix avec un problème car jean
secteur qui foutent un fou frères david
et marc dufour remboursement d'arrhes
départ de ces bons non je peux pas te
vendre pour s'amuser à acheter à crédit
peux tu va rembourser quel prix mais qui
n'a que deux mois à la télé frères matin
quand j'appuie sur un bouton il ya
canal+ temps quand j'appuie chantons et
on se passe rien
c'est pas son truc
[Musique]